hey guys Ryan right here I have a
there's a dog right here there's a dog
oh come here for a second puppy I want
to show these guys this is Sally's dog
you could just hear you know much jinwu
yeah I'm such an [ __ ] what's her name
again
honeypot I smoked a bowl of honeypot
today okay now I'm gonna get off you're
gonna distract the viewers from this
awesome story I'm about to tell so
recently I shared a story about this
time I got a blow job when I was high so
I thought like you know let's not end it
there okay I want to I want to make sure
you guys get a really good image of me
I'm gonna tell you by the time I got
arrested this time was uh was a fun time
I committed criminal activities
that you wouldn't think are really like
a huge law pretty good what happened was
those were my friend Tommy I'm gonna use
his real name that's how we'll consider
it I mean and I we love to [ __ ] around
like an eighth grade we went to school
till eighth grade he was nominated class
clown and I was nominated funniest guy
and we both agreed it should have been
switched around yeah yeah anyway so
Tommy and I would love to [ __ ] around
after we got out of eighth grade we
would uh you know start off with the
usual like you bring girls in the car
with you and then you're driving around
town and cuz we do now [ __ ] Drive at
16 you shout stuff at random people that
was fun or just doing were just
ridiculous things we used to open the
doors and everyone in the car and like
look behind us real fast the person
behind us and then just shut the door
and then one time we did we did door we
did door knocking door knocking the cell
it's way worse than these oh yeah what
do you do with door knocking is you
basically get those strings and then you
go really late
you have to do it at like 1:00 in the
morning to make this work so then you
take the string that you need like the
long [ __ ] strings you know I'm
talking about where this call like your
role is so you need those long strings
and then you put it to the door knock
the other things like clang against the
[ __ ] door
you know like knock and then so they
take the string and you go back to your
car and then you just keep [ __ ]
knocking obnoxiously until like all
that's for it is so you get the
satisfaction of seeing someone's
reaction to someone's like some people
are so tired some people are so like
[ __ ] like scared that they'll end up
just like being so confused they'll hear
the door knocking but they don't see
anyone and no one's thinking they put a
string there so it looks like there's
like a haunting going on oh man it was
it was magnificent I loved doing that we
used to steal this guy's a water jug
that was a lot of fun at one time he
chased us in the car we were just like
yell stuff at his house and steal the
water jugs I used to take I hope I'm not
telling this these stories and then
someone goes wait a minute that [ __ ]
happen exactly to me I used to take the
lamps the lights on people's be darts
and I would just steal them and maybe
throw them at cars broke a windshield
once and yeah I was just I was just an
obnoxious kid back then yeah 16 now how
did I get arrested okay we wanted to
take this to the next level I was at
7-eleven with Tommy and then we noticed
there is the thing there called the cap
gun now the cap gun it comes with those
little caps that I used to smash it with
hammers with my friend Brandon Melgar
shout-out to you buddy
and then he we would smash it cuz it
sound like you know she's like a bullet
jock thing and I was like in something
like five bucks so we bought it and I
was like okay what should we do with
this and so the first person we decided
to try this on we took a job is like so
mean we took a cap gun and put the caps
in
and then we just pulled up to the
sidewalk and then we looked at a guy
like for like 10 seconds and he notice
us looking in him and I was like hey
that I whipped out the cuttin and I shot
it at him and he thought he was gonna
get shot at that moment but then we
thought it was so funny like looking
back on it I'm like damn we're [ __ ]
for doing that but the second person was
like by far the worst thing I've ever
done to another human being um after
this experience this man probably went
on a spiritual journey so we were
driving around a neighborhood right and
Tommy always drove his truck and then we
were driving around a neighborhood and
then we passed this guy and he was
walking like three dogs and these three
small puppies and then we turns around
slowly and then he's like alright I'm
gonna circle the guy so he starts to
circle him I get out of the window I
point the gun and I'm like [ __ ] I start
shooting and he starts losing his [ __ ]
he starts going oh god please he starts
losing it man [ __ ] like he really
thought he was gonna die right there so
if you're watching this I am so sorry
for doing that I know yeah compared to
that as long as that yeah [ __ ] yeah I
thought he was gonna die because of me
well I'm that guy I mean we didn't stop
there we did a few more times than other
people like they would get shot at and
there we go like oh like some people
thought me who got shot at they were
reflex would go oh like that thing girls
thought it was [ __ ] funny whenever we
did it so we just did it to make girls
laugh really then one day I get a call
from Tommy and I'm like an hour away
from where I live I didn't have a car
yeah he's like dude um you got to come
back you got to come back now I was like
why he's like I just got arrested they
have camera footage of me driving the
truck and there were like two people
that reported us and he's like you gotta
turn yourself in or else we're gonna
come get you
it's a I truck so I didn't tell my
parents anything I just [ __ ] was like
yeah I think we gotta go back home and
then I got back home and bam he shows up
and first off for some reason I'm like
[ __ ] excited and I'm like I can't
wait to tell people this story this is
so funny about to get arrested so I went
and turned myself in it was interesting
um the man who arrested us I'll never
forget his name because he made sure
people remembered it it was Detective
goossens
and on his card was a picture of a goose
that's the detective okay
a real corny detective you slings rahi I
like Tommy try lying his way out and
normally that works with Tommy Tommy it
was great at that but with me
this second he asked me a question I was
like yeah I did it I was just being
really childish and I'm sorry I [ __ ]
up so I just admitted it and he actually
I did an episode of It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia once and had a line and he
actually remembered me from that yeah
him and I had a bond the time I got
arrested he read me my rights and
everything like that I was in his
custody but the little fingerprint thing
no cops have my fingerprints god dammit